You may or may not be surprised to learn
that there's really been no real financial compensation at all,
for Henrietta Lacks's family; however, the Moorehouse School of
Medicine has donated money for Henrietta's and her daughter's grave
stone. And two members of the family now sit
on a committee at the NIH, who decides who gets
access to the genome information and there's a promise to
acknowledge the family in scientific papers published, using the information.
This is a great example of a story
that changed how we think about medical ethics.
It's a fascinating story that you can read
far more about online, but I highly recommend
the book The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lacks
by Rebecca Skloot. Go to the forums and
chat with your classmates about what you think,
the most moral outcome of this scenario should be.